llevo 15 años de discusiones incluyendo
cuatro años de negociaciones formales
para que los estados miembros de la ONU
llegaran finalmente a un acuerdo el
primer tratado internacional para la
protección del altamar se adoptó el
lunes por consenso su principal objetivo
la conservación y el uso sostenible de
la biodiversidad marina
el océano es la fuente de nuestra vida
en este planeta y hoy usted le ha dado
una nueva vida y una nueva Esperanza
para que tenga una oportunidad de luchar
usted lo hizo los océanos del mundo
están amenazados en varios frentes el
cambio climático está afectando a
nuestro planeta perturbando los patrones
meteorológicos y las corrientes
oceánicas y alterando los ecosistemas
marinos y las especies que viven en
ellos
la altamar representa las aguas
internacionales y por lo tanto no está
bajo la jurisdicción de ningún estado en
particular ocupa casi la mitad del
planeta y más del 60% de los océanos
proporciona la mitad del oxígeno que
respiramos y limita el calentamiento
global al observar parte del co2 emitido
por las actividades humanas la
herramienta estrella del nuevo tratado
la creación de áreas marinas protegidas
en estas aguas internacionales que
podrían tener un gran impacto en las
actividades nacionales de pesca
exploración y extracción
una medida clave los estudios de impacto
antes de autorizar una actividad en
altamar Bajo su control los países
tendrán que estudiar su impacto
potencial en el medio Marino
corresponderá a la futura conferencia de
las partes es decidir a los Estados
miembros aplicar medidas concretas de
protección en estas vastas zonas
alejadas de las tierras nacionales
algunos expertos ya apuestan por los
satélites para vigilar e identificar las
infracciones ahora al menos 60 estados
deben ratificar el tratado para que
entre en vigor idealmente para la
próxima conferencia de la ONU sobre los
océanos que se celebrará en Niza en
junio de 2025